so here's a basic pro tip don't buy
iPhone se it's that simple
just don't buy it now I'm kidding let's
get into some details of why you should
not buy the 20/20 version of the iPhone
se what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the brand new
iPhone se and why I personally believe
it is not the right budget phone to buy
in 2020 if we look at it in America
they've released that for 399 USD which
should equate to 610 Australian dollars
with a direct conversion at the very bad
conversion rate at the moment but
instead it equates to 749 Australian
dollars for the very bottom of the range
iPhone se now this is meant to be a
budget frame from Apple and yet all
they've done is taken an old iPhone 6 7
8 whatever you want to compare it to and
thrown it back into the market at a very
expensive price in Australia from being
honest with you yes you do get the a13
chip which is the same chip in the
iPhone 1111 Promax everything in the
levant series you do get 4k video
recording and all these great little
knick-knack quirks that are going to
make you want to think it's a good phone
but in reality it's a big forehead a big
chin touch ID fingerprint sensor on the
bottom where you actually have to touch
the button it's a physical button it has
a 720p HD screen instead of a 1080p it's
all the way back down to 60 Hertz a
second it isn't a high refresh rate like
all the new flagship SAR but it is a
budget phone so I guess that's what you
kind of have to expect you have to take
some hits and the good with the bad now
what really gets me is the fact that you
can get much better if not even
equivalent iPhones for significantly
less right now in 2020 in Australia so
for example if I read you something here
that are taking note of before the
iPhone 7 a refurbished model given you
can pick it up for 255 Australian
dollars or equivalent to a hundred and
sixty US dollars that's the shape from a
comparative
interview and iphone7 and the brand new
se besides the chip itself and a few
little knickknacks here and there it
isn't too much of a difference and if
you're looking for a budget phone this
is one of the best budget phones you can
buy now on the other hand if you are
looking to spend that $749 why would you
not go out and buy a brand-new iPhone 11
which the chip was designed for it was
built for it and it has all the better
features you can easily pick up an
iPhone 11 this 879 Australian or 575 USD
that's an extra hundred and twenty
dollars or so for a huge difference in
performance models specs absolutely
everything now my personal opinion I
would be buying the iPhone 11 over the
iPhone se because as we all know iPhones
hold their value really really well if
you buy an SI it's going to drop in
value pretty quickly but if you buy an
iPhone 11 in two three years time it's
still going to hold a pretty decent
value when you unbox the device as well
or year inside a five watt charger a
lightning cable and a lightning set of
headphones there's no headphone jack in
this budget phone which if you compare
it to any other Android device out there
and yes if you're new to the channel I
do use Android but I also use Apple
devices for a lot of my stuff so I run a
pretty unbiased opinion when it comes to
these devices if you were to compare an
eight hundred and fifty dollar Android
device to an eight hundred and fifty
dollar budget iPhone you'd quickly find
that the Android device is much better
in every way shape or form because
there's a lot more competition in that
space unfortunately unfortunately I
guess for Apple Apple doesn't have this
competition so they can bang out an $800
budget phone and everybody will go and
buy it because it's an Apple device
personally I wouldn't buy the iPhone se
I would recommend going to that iPhone
11 stage if you can actually afford the
little bit more of a jump up or looking
for a refurbished model of the iPhone 7
for 250 dollars that's ridiculous that
is a very good price point for a
brand-new in-the-box
perfect condition iPhone anyway that's
all for me today go
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed my little rant here today if
you did smash that subscribe button
20:20 style were almost at a 2,000
subscriber count number which is really
good news really excited to see that
tick over but because we asked in
quarantine period that means we're
pumping out a lot more content as well
so usually I'd see you every Monday but
today being Wednesday I will see you on
Friday